>> JOINING US NOW, CNN CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
KAITLAN COLLINS AND POLITICAL
ANALYST AND SENIOR POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," MAGGIE HABERMAN.
IT'S WORTH NOTING, KAITLAN, THAT
SOMEONE ON THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM
SIGNED A DOCUMENT ATTESTING THAT
ALL OF THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS HAD BEEN TURNED BACK
IN AND THEY HADN'T.
>> YEAH, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS FIRST REPORTED BY MAGGIE.
I THINK THE REVELATION THAT A
LAWYER FOR TRUMP SIGNED THIS
DOCUMENT SAYING THERE IS NOTHING
ELSE HERE WHEN, OF COURSE, AS WE
KNOW BY THE SEARCH WARRANT,
THERE WAS MUCH MORE STUFF THERE.
GOES TO SPEAK TO THE LEVEL OF
WHAT THEY WERE TELLING
INVESTIGATORS AT THE TIME AND
THE WAY THEY VIEWED THAT JUNE
3rd MEETING, WHICH IS THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS MORE CASUAL,
FRIENDLIER THAN THEY BELIEVED.
TRUMP STOPPED BY AND MET WITH
THE INVESTIGATORS WHO WERE AT
MAR-A-LAGO, MEETING WITH HIS
ATTORNEYS AND THEN HIS ATTORNEYS
SHOWED THEM WHERE THE DOCUMENTS
WERE BEING KEPT.
THEY KNEW THERE WERE STILL
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY WENT THROUGH THEM, TOOK
SOME WITH THEM.
THIS RAISES THE QUESTIONS OF WHY
HIS ATTORNEY SIGNED THIS LETTER
SAYING THERE WAS NOTHING ELSE
THERE.
IT FEEDS INTO THE ARGUMENT HE'S
MAKING THAT HE DECLASSIFIED ALL
OF THAT INFORMATION ANYWAY.
>> LET'S STICK WITH THE LETTER,
WHICH IS SOMETHING YOU BROKE
OVER THE WEEKEND.
TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU
KNOW, WHO SIGNED IT AND WHY IT
FITS IN THIS TIMELINE.
>> Reporter: THERE WERE TWO
ATTORNEYS AT THAT MEETING, EVAN
CORCORAN, EVELYN BOBB.
ONE SIGNED A PAPER ASSERTING
THERE WAS NO MORE TOP SECRET
MATERIAL.
IT MAY HAVE JUST BEEN TOP
SECRET.
TOP SECRET, SCI, THERE WAS NO
MORE THERE.
WHAT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME IS
WHETHER THE TRUMP FOLKS ARE
GOING TO TRY TO SAY WHAT'S IN
THE BOXES.
IT RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE
ELSE ON THE PROPERTY DOCUMENTS
WERE FOUND.
WHY THEY DID THAT, I'M NOT SURE.
THIS MEETING WAS IN RESPONSE, WE
SHOULD NOTE, TO A SUBPOENA THEY
FILED IN MAY.
YES, THE TRUMP FOLKS HAVE
REPEATEDLY SAID, WE WERE IN
CONVERSATIONS, THIS WAS CASUAL.
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS AFTER
SUBPOENAS.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS THAT A SUBPOENA
GETS EXECUTED AND IT'S HOSTILE.
HOWEVER, I THINK FROM THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PERSPECTIVE,
THIS WAS A LITTLE MORE ADV
ADVERSARIAL THAN I THINK THE
TRUMP FOLKS ARE MAKING IT.
I'M NOT CLEAR SO SOMETHING YOU
RAISE, THOUGH, AND THERE ARE SO
MANY QUESTIONS WE DON'T HAVE
ANSWERS TO.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO SAY TO
FOLKS.
ONE IS THEY CLEARLY KNEW THERE
WERE OTHER PRESIDENTIAL ACT
MATERIALS THEY WERE LEAVING
BEHIND ON JUNE 3rd.
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS TOOK STUFF THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
WHY DID THAT ALL GET LEFT BEHIND
AND WHAT HAPPENS BETWEEN THE
JUNE 3rd MEETING, WE KNOW THEY
SUBPOENAED AND LOOKED AT SOME
SURVEILLANCE FOOTAGE AND SAW
SOMETHING THAT CONCERNED THEM.
WE'RE NOT SURE EXACTLY WHEN THAT
PERIOD WAS THAT CONCERNED THEM,
BUT AT SOME POINT BETWEEN JUNE
3rd AND LAST MONDAY IS WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENED THAT PROVOKED
THIS SEARCH WARRANT.
>> WHICH IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
WE ALSO, WHEN WE WERE REPORTING
ON THIS LAST MONDAY AS IT WAS
HAPPENING, WE WERE HEARING FROM
TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS AND PEOPLE WHO
HAD BEEN SPEAKING WITH HIM, THEY
COULDN'T HAVE THOUGHT THIS
INVESTIGATION WAS OVER, IT DIED,
IT WASN'T REALLY GOING ANYWHERE.
AFTER THEY MET WITH THOSE
INVESTIGATORS.
WE LATER LEARNED THERE WAS A
SUBPOENA SO THE ARGUMENT YOU'RE
HEARING FROM TRUMP'S ALLIES, WHY
DIDN'T THEY JUST ASK FOR THESE
DOCUMENTS?
THEY DID.
THAT'S ANOTHER UNANSWERED
QUESTION, WHY THERE WAS SO MUCH
STUFF THERE THEY WERE UNWILLING
TO TURN OVER.
>> PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
BELIEVE THE INTERMEDIATE THINGS
TURNED OVER WERE SPECIAL STEPS
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SOMEONE ELSE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
GIVEN BE THAT COURTESY.
YOU ALSO REPORT THAT ADVISERS
URGED HIM TO TURN THESE
DOCUMENTS OVER.
SOME PEOPLE IN HIS ORBIT KNEW
THEY WERE THERE EVEN AS THE
LAWYER OR LAWYERS WERE ATTESTING
THEY WERE NOT.
>> SO, AGAIN, JUST ON A WHAT
WE'RE NOT CLEAR ON, WE KNOW
PEOPLE WERE URGING HIM TO RETURN
THIS STUFF, TO BE CLEAR, FOR A
YEAR.
BUT THEN IN JANUARY, WHEN THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES COMES AND GETS
ROUGHLY 15 -- NOT ROUGHLY -- 15
BOXES OF MATERIAL.
AT SOME POINT THEY DISCOVER
THERE IS STILL MATERIAL THERE
AND THAT'S WHEN THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT, YOU'VE GOT
TO GIVE THE REST BACK, STARTS
HAPPENING.
WHETHER HIS LAWYERS -- JUST TO
BE CLEAR TO WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME WHETHER THE
PEOPLE ASSERTING THINGS WERE
GIVEN BACK KNEW THAT THERE WAS
STILL STUFF THAT REMAINED.
WE DON'T KNOW.
THEY ALSO SEARCHED HIS OFFICE
AND HIS RESIDENCE.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE OTHER
MATERIAL WAS FOUND.
IS THERE A CONCEIVABLE WORLD,
ABSOLUTELY A THEORY, THAT SOME
MATERIAL WAS MOVED FROM THAT
STORAGE AREA AND PUT SOMEWHERE
ELSE?
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
>> SINCE YOU'RE RAISING
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS --
>> THAT'S BASICALLY ALL I'M
DOING.
>> THIS IS YOUR LIFE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE BIGGEST
QUESTIONS ARE?
>> THE BIGGEST QUESTION IS WHY
HE HAD THESE.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST ANSWER.
WHY DID HE HAVE THEM AND WHY DID
HE NOT WANT TO GIVE THEM BACK?
WITH DONALD TRUMP THE RANGE OF
ANSWERS IS A RANGE.
IT COULD BE BECAUSE HE FELT
CERTAIN THINGS WERE COOL, LIKE
THE TRINKETS HE HAD AT TRUMP
TOWER AND HE WOULD SHOW PEOPLE.
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT THERE WAS
SOMETHING ADVANTAGEOUS TO HIM
HAVING IT.
THAT'S AN OPTION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WOULD BE.
THEN THE OTHER QUESTION IS WHAT
THE MATERIAL IS.
WHAT EXACTLY THE FBI WAS
SEARCHING FOR, THE NATURE OF IT.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CONSIDERED IT
SENSITIVE.
THEY CONSIDERED IT MATERIAL.
THEY COULDN'T LEAVE LYING AROUND
AT THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
UNSECURED CLUB THAT HAS BEEN A
SECURITY CONCERN FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT HE USED TO RUN
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
>> KAITLAN, WHAT'S TELLING IS
THE DEFENSE FROM DONALD TRUMP,
FROM THOSE CLOSE TO HIM, FROM
THOSE SUPPORTING HIM, IT JUST IS
COMPLETELY CHANGING OVERTIME.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WATCHING THOSE
FOLKS THROW SPAGHETTI AGAINST A
WALL IN THE HOPES THAT SOMETHING
WOULD STICK.
>> THAT'S NOT NEW.
WE'VE SEEN THAT BEFORE WHEN THEY
HAVE DIFFERING EXPLANATIONS FOR
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT
WENT INTO LAW BECAUSE OF RICHARD
NIXON.
WHEN HE LEFT OFFICE, HE WANTED
TO TAKE HIS DOCUMENTS AND
POTENTIALLY HIS RECORDINGS WITH
THAT.
BEFORE THAT, PRESIDENTS COULD
COME AND GO, TAKE WITH THEM WHAT
THEY WANTED.
THERE WERE NO RULES REG LATING
IT.
AFTER HE LEFT OFFICE, THEY
CREATED ONE.
IT WAS SPECIFIC TO HIM AND
PASSED A LAW A FEW YEARS LATER
SAYING IT APPLIES TO ALL
PRESIDENTS.
IT'S ANYTHING YOU WRITE, A
NUCLEAR CODES OR A DOODLE IN THE
OFFICE.
IT BELONGS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE SECOND THING IS WHEN IT
COMES TO MAR-A-LAGO AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT WAS THERE
AND HOW IT WAS SECURED.
WE'VE SEEN THESE CASES IN THE
PAST WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TRIED TO
BREACH MAR-A-LAGO.
PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN INSIDE PAST
SECURITY.
THAT'S WHY IT RAISES SO MANY
CONCERNS.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHO IS AROUND
HIM.
IT IS A PRIVATE CLUB BUT A
LITTLE FREE-WHEELING.
EVERYONE IS TRYING TO GET HIS
ATTENTION.
THIS WAS A CONCERN FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY PROFESSIONALS WHEN HE
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> AND THAT'S "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" REPORTING, WHICH MAGGIE
AND EVERYONE HAS HAD A PIECE OF
THIS.
THE BIG CONCERN WAS JUST GET
THIS STUFF OUT.
GET THIS STUFF OUT OF
MAR-A-LAGO.
WHETHER THERE ARE CRIMINAL
CHARGES, YOU KNOW, IT'S RELATED
BUT THAT'S ANOTHER THING THAT
THEY WILL BE DOING.
THEY WANTED TO GET THAT STUFF
OUT FIRST.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SHIFTING
JUSTIFICATIONS FROM TRUMP WORLD.
NOW YOU HAVE A PIECE ON THIS
TODAY AS WELL.
IN WHICH YOU QUOTE FORMER
AMBASSADOR JOHN BOLTON.
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS IDEA, THIS DEFENSE OF
A BLANKET UNIVERSAL
DECLASSIFICATION OF DOCUMENTS BY
TRUMP.
>> RIGHT.
TRUMP'S OFFICE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT LAST WEEK -- AT THE
END OF LAST WEEK SAYING HE HAD A
QUOTE, UNQUOTE, STANDING ORDER
THAT DOCUMENTS THAT LEFT HIS
OFFICE TO THE OVAL OFFICE TO
BECOME DECLASSIFIED.
JOHN BOLTON SAID HE WAS NOT TOLD
OF SUCH AN ORDER.
HE STILL HAD COLLEAGUES WHO HE
WAS TALKING WITH AT THE NSC.
HIS POINT WAS, EVEN IF YOU
ACCEPT THEIR CLAIM THAT HE CAN
JUST STAND OVER A DOCUMENT AND
SAY, IT'S DECLASSIFIED, THERE
HAS TO BE A LOG OF IT, A RECORD
OF IT.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME RECEIPTS,
ESSENTIALLY, SO PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT'S DECLASSIFIED AND WHAT'S
NOT.
HE MADE ANOTHER POINT, IF THIS
STUFF IS ALL DECLASSIFIED, IT'S
NOW SUBJECT TO PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUEST.
ALL OF US COULD TRY TO GET IT.
I'M NOT SURE THAT MATERIAL
ACTUALLY FALLS INTO THAT GROUP.
>> TRUMP IS TRYING TO OPEN A
LINE OF COMMUNICATION WITH
MERRICK GARLAND?
IT'S KIND OF FOGGY HERE.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS A VERY LONG
HISTORY OF TRYING TO SORT OF
BOTH NEGOTIATE WITH PROSECUTORS
LOOKING INTO HIM.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES.
AND ALSO TO TRY TO SEND A
FRIENDLY WORD, QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
TO PEOPLE WRITING ABOUT HIM OR
LOOKING INTO HIM OR WHATEVER.
THIS APPEARED TO FALL INTO THAT
CATEGORY.
HE HAD AN INTERMEDIARY TALK TO
SOMEBODY AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND SEND A MESSAGE
AND THE MESSAGE WAS, YOU KNOW,
THE COUNTRY IS -- I'M MISQUOTING
HERE BUT ESSENTIALLY THE COUNTRY
IS ON FIRE.
HE KNEW THIS BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN
TALKING TO PEOPLE IN HIS
MOVEMENT AND THEY'RE VERY UPSET
AND WHAT COULD HE DO TO TAKE
DOWN THE TEMPERATURE?
THAT CAN BE READ A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS.
I THINK IT WAS READ A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT IT'S VERY IN
KEEPING WITH HOW HE HANDLES
THESE KIND OF SITUATIONS.
>> BEFORE HE WAS IMPEACHED THE
SECOND TIME, HE ATTEMPTED TO
TALK TO HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI
ABOUT THIS AND ESSENTIALLY GET
HER NOT TO PURSUE IMPEACHMENT.
WHICH WE KNOW SHE DID.
HE WAS IN THE CONFERENCE IN NEW
YORK WITH WORLD LEADERS WHEN
THAT HAPPENED.
BUT HE TRIED TO GET IN TOUCH
WITH HER.
>> AND HE TALKED TO JAMES COMEY
SEVERAL TIMES.
>> AND TRIED TO TALK TO MUELLER.
>> I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT, AND THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE GOT TO SPEAK TO YOU.
THIS IS THE KICKER IN YOUR
PIECE.
TALK TO US MORE ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
AGAIN, HOW YOU'RE SEEING IT.
>> WELL, THIS IS -- ALL WE KNOW
IS WHAT WE REPORTED.
THERE WAS THIS CONVERSATION
WHERE AN INTERMEDIARY, SOMEBODY
CLOSE TO TRUMP, REACHED OUT TO
SOMEBODY AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO SEND THIS MESSAGE
ABOUT TRUMP WANTING TO TAKE THE
TEMPERATURE DOWN.
YOU COULD HEAR THIS IN ONE WORLD
AS DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING TO
OPEN SOME KIND OF LINE OF
COMMUNICATION.
YOU COULD HEAR THIS IN ANOTHER
WORLD OF DONALD TRUMP REMINDING
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT HE
HAS A LOT OF FANS OUT THERE WHO
ARE PRETTY UPSET, SOME OF WHOM
AS WE SAW THE OTHER DAY, ONE OF
WHOM WENT TO AN FBI OFFICE AND
ENGAGED IN A STANDOFF WITH THEM.
SO, I THINK THAT IS HOW -- THAT
LAST DEFINITION IS HOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE HEARD IT.